[Music]
on this saturday night
social bubble burst ontario cracks down
on parties
we can't have these wild parties right
now the new province-wide limits on
gatherings
as the cases go up the politicians
testing positive for covet 19.
it's unrealistic and unsafe to expect
everybody to to be sitting in the
chamber
will this change the way we govern plus
warning a supreme court justice
with peter ginsberg was a hero and icon
the republican race to replace rbg
before the election
and former prime minister john turner
dead at the age of 91.
national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us if we have learned anything from the
first wave of the pandemic it's that
covid19
can be contained through aggressive
measures in ontario officials are so
worried about the recent rise in cases
the government has extended restrictions
on private gatherings to the entire
province
premier doug ford is essentially popping
the balloon
on big bashes indoor gatherings are now
limited
to 10 people outdoor gatherings are
limited
to 25 people all gatherings still
require physical distancing
the province is in the process of
imposing new finds for people who throw
large parties
the organizers face fines of at least
ten thousand dollars
and guests can be fined seven hundred
and fifty dollars
each today ontario recorded another 407
new cases
quebec has the biggest spike with 427
new cases
manitoba added 18. saskatchewan reported
11
atlantic canada bc alberta and the
territories
do not report on weekends two federal
leaders aaron o'toole and e francois
have both tested positive for covet 19.
neither
will now be able to attend next week's
throne speech
their positive tests have some
questioning whether there should be more
changes to the way politicians do
business
during the pandemic michael couture has
our top story tonight
this meeting with quebec premier
francois lago was the last time
conservative leader aaron o'toole was
seen public
the federal leader has since tested
positive for covet 19.
and while ago's results came back
negative he is self-isolating as a
precaution
now lego was in ottawa friday meeting
with three other premiers who all say
they're fine i wouldn't hesitate to get
tested but i'm feeling good
i'd rather the people that have the
symptoms
get tested if that's one extra person
getting tested and i'm not there
that's great officials in the offices of
manitoba premier brian pallister
and alberta premier jason kenney say
both are monitoring for symptoms but
they're not self-isolating because they
follow distancing and masking guidelines
in ottawa
as seen in these photos posted on
twitter still the fact that o'toole
and block quebec leader eve francois
blaschette tested positive
underscores the importance of doing
politics differently
in a pandemic you really have to do that
with safety in mind
and that boils down to fewer people in
the room
spreading out wearing masks and doing as
much virtual as possible
that sentiment echoed by
intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc
we think it's unrealistic and unsafe to
expect everybody to
to be sitting in the chamber but we want
to ensure that it can be safely and
securely done
remotely that's just one part of the
fight against covet 19.
testing is another but lineups at
testing centers
continue to cause frustration the line
hasn't moved for like five ten minutes
so i'm just going to go somewhere else
instead
premier ford addressed those concerns
directly calling on health canada to
approve a simpler saliva test for
covid19
even though one of his lead medical
officers doesn't seem convinced
you go in you get the strips you spit on
the strip
and then you can see instantly as it was
described to me it's almost like a
pregnancy test
they don't need a health professional to
administer them
but you do lose a bit of sensitivity so
they're sort of pros and cons antigen
tests like the one ford is referring to
haven't proven
as effective as nasal swabs so for now
patience also remains a big part of
fighting this pandemic
mike liquiter global news ottawa
parliament will resume on wednesday with
a throne speech focused on the kova 19
pandemic
more than six months since the pandemic
was declared
is the government prepared for a second
wave mercedes stephenson puts that
question to intergovernmental affairs
minister
dominic leblanc for this week's edition
of the west block
just days away from the speech from the
throne that will set the agenda for the
trudeau government going forward
canadians are seeing a spike in coded 19
cases
and long lines for testing creating
anxiety about the possibility of a
second wave
something that's already been declared
in ottawa
this week on the west block we'll talk
to intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc to ask him if the
federal government has been
sufficiently prepared for this second
wave now that they have had
months to prepare for it where are we at
on the acquiring of personal protective
equipment
rapid testing and more money for the
provinces to be able to run those
testing facilities
provincial governments which obviously
have the responsibility to organize
testing sites to organize the delivery
of health care
have been telling us that the additional
resources that we allocated a total of
almost 19 billion dollars as i said but
11 billion of it directly related to the
health care needs
for the restart of the economy and of
the return to school
these are all things we've been
discussing with provinces and
territories
and frankly we've met their ask in terms
of additional funding
there's a lot of questions about what
will actually be in that throne speech
justin trudeau
had said that it was going to be
transformational bold major change
but with the rising number of covet
cases it seems like the government may
be shifting more
to focusing on the pandemic than some of
the big social program changes or
environmental regulations
they were looking at i asked dominic
leblanc about
what we can expect to see on wednesday
there won't be any surprises mercedes
we've been saying
very clearly that the pandemic and the
health and safety of canadians
is the priority so people shouldn't be
surprised that
the government's focus will be squarely
on that it seems as though appetite for
a fall election is dampening on
parliament hill but the opposition will
not give a guarantee that they support
the throne speech and prime minister
justin trudeau has said that while he
doesn't want an election
he believes that one could be conducted
safely elections canada should be
reporting back soon on how to have an
election during a pandemic
that said prime minister justin trudeau
called two by-elections
in ontario this week that will test both
pandemic elections
and the liberals support we'll have more
on this on the west block tomorrow
from calgary i'm mercedes stephenson
new data shows covet-19 infections among
canadian health care workers
was nearly double the global tally in
july
according to the world health
organization health care workers made up
10 percent of
world coven 19 infections in that month
in canada nearly 20 percent of health
care workers just over 21 000
tested positive as of july 23rd the
hardest hit provinces were quebec and
ontario
where 12 healthcare workers died from
covet 19.
tensions are reaching a boiling point in
nova scotia
over a lobster fishing dispute between
indigenous harvesters and commercial
fishermen
the assembly of nova scotia chiefs has
declared a state of emergency effective
immediately in response to what it calls
political
unrest and violence it will establish an
emergency command center to support
families
it's also asking for help from the
department of fisheries and rcmp
yesterday the sipana katy first nation
started its own self-regulated lobster
fishery but their lines were later cut
the lobster grounds where they're
setting traps are currently out of
season
to commercial fishers who are outraged
the death of u.s supreme court justice
ruth bader ginsburg has already become a
political
issue the republican-controlled senate
is determined to move ahead with whoever
donald trump wants in that job
before the november election rbg was
only one of four liberals on the
nine-seat bench
and if the republicans get their vote
through the balance of power
will be a huge shift towards the
conservatives as jennifer johnson
reports
the democrats have a huge fight on their
hands
americans are gathering outside the u.s
supreme court mourning the death of
justice ruth bader ginsburg
a champion of women minorities and
gender equality rights
i think that with bader ginsburg was a
hero and
icon i think she's such a great example
for women it's like a gut punch
and it just i just had to come just
being in the area i just had to come
here
in 1993 ginsburg became only the second
woman in u.s history
to take a seat on the supreme court she
consistently delivered progressive votes
on the most divisive social issues of
the day chief justice john roberts says
they have lost a jurist of historic
stature
justice stephen breyer called her a rock
of righteousness
even u.s president donald trump never a
friend of ginsburg's
praised her lifelong accomplishments she
led an amazing life
what else can you say she was an amazing
woman
whether you agreed or not hours after
ginsburg's death
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
said he will move forward with whomever
president trump nominates
a stark turn around from his position
four years ago
when he held up then president barack
obama's pick to replace justice antonin
scalia for 11 months
until trump took office minorities
lgbtq people and women's reproductive
rights activists are very concerned
about the future under a potentially
even more conservative supreme court
we're screwed 50 years of progress for
women's rights is just going to be gone
president trump has tweeted his
replacement for ginsburg will happen in
a timely manner
we're just not there yet in terms of
entertaining names the president's
obviously put forward two lists on the
american people
know exactly where the president stands
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden firing back
voters should pick the president
and the president should pick the
justice
for the senate to consider ginsburg's
death will bring more bitter partisan
fighting
to an already divided congress her
legacy
championing against discrimination will
long be remembered
but her death may be a catalyst for a
new chapter in american political
history
jennifer johnson global news washington
the deadly poison
ricin has been discovered in an envelope
addressed to president trump and
canadian law enforcement is involved in
the investigation
the suspicious package was intercepted
before reaching the white house
it's believed the package originated
from canada a female suspect has been
identified
ricin is a lethal toxin with no known
antidote
multiple packages containing ricin were
addressed to former president barack
obama
during his time in office in person
early voting began
in four states for the 2020 presidential
election
long lines stretched for hours outside
polling stations
as voters arrived to cast ballots in
virginia south dakota
wyoming and minnesota both joe biden and
donald trump campaigned in that state
where trump narrowly lost in 2016.
along america's west coast there are
more evacuation orders
because the flames from those wildfires
are moving even closer
in southern california thousands of
people were forced from their homes and
more
are preparing to leave the bobcat fire
is burning in the los angeles national
forest about 80 kilometers from downtown
l.a
and it grew quickly overnight winds
whipped up to 70 kilometers an hour
fanning the already towering flames
there's another positive development in
alexi navalny's recovery
the russian opposition leader who was
poisoned is able to walk
the valani posted his image of him
walking down the stairs at the hospital
in germany that has been caring for him
he says he's regaining his physical and
mental capacity
five days ago he was taken off a
ventilator and able to breathe on his
own for the first time
the valny became ill on a flight from
siberia to moscow in august
his family believes the kremlin ordered
the poisoning
but the russian government denies it
coming up a long career in politics but
a short stint
as canada's 17th prime minister
and how one event can turn into a covet
catastrophe
global national is back in two minutes
john turner has died at the age of 91.
he was this country's
17th prime minister serving for just 79
days in 1984
but his career in politics was long
serving in the cabinets of lester b
pearson and pierre trudeau during
turner's time in trudeau's government
he was finance minister and he and his
boss didn't always get along
ross lord takes a look back at john
turner's path to politics
he was the golden boy of canadian
politics a brilliant scholar
a superb athlete fluently bilingual and
good-looking
when he entered politics in 1962 the
future looked bright for john turner
lester pearson made him a cabinet
minister and in 1968
just six years after entering politics a
young turner ran for the liberal
leadership but he came up short
defeated by an even more charismatic
politician pierre trudeau
turner served as justice and finance
minister under trudeau
but in 1975 he shocked canadians by
resigning
amidst rumors he got tired of butting
heads with trudeau
turner retreated to life as a corporate
lawyer but he did not abandon his
political ambitions
[Applause]
the two leaders in 1984 pierre trudeau
quit
and turner assumed the role of prodigal
son
returning to assume the leadership of
the liberal party 1862.
at the convention turner beat jean
cretchette was sworn in as prime
minister
and almost immediately called an
election
those facts are not correct that
campaign saw
turner on the receiving end of one of
the most definitive knockout punches
of canadian politics before resigning
pierre trudeau made 200 patronage
appointments
and turner had to defend them when he
debated conservative leader brian
mulroney
i do had an option sir you could have
said i am not going to do it this is
wrong for canada
the liberals were bulldozed in the 84
election winning just
40 seats but turner held on holding
fast in the face of backroom grumbling
and liberal infighting
in the 1988 election he thought he'd
found the issue
that would propel him back to power free
trade
turner arguing powerfully it was a deal
that would destroy canada
i believe that you've sold us out
turner's stronger performance did win
the liberals more seats
but they still came a distance second to
brian mulrooney's conservatives
it's my intention to resign as leader of
the liberal party of canada
soon after turner resigned as liberal
leader staying on as an mp until 1993
the golden boy having tasted as much
defeat as victory
in his political career
ross lord global news
super spreading wedding still ahead how
covet 19 reached
past the guest list
you're watching global national
[Music]
many jurisdictions around the world are
imposing limits on the number of people
who can come together
at one time that's to help prevent super
spreader
events these are incidents where
multiple cases of cova 19
are traced back to an infected person in
a crowded environment where physical
distancing is limited
this happens at gatherings like weddings
funerals and parties or in venues like
nightclubs and places of worship
that one person infects the people they
come into contact with
and then those infected people spread it
to others
it has become clear that so-called super
spreader incidents have played a huge
role
in the transmission of the virus mike
derle shows us how a single event can
have
widespread and deadly consequences
the owners of the big moose inn admit
they messed up the head count
what began as a wedding reception of 65
quickly bloomed to 100
double maine's indoor gathering limit of
50 people from that one event where
masks and distancing were ignored
maine is now dealing with 176 new cases
covet 19 right now is not on the other
side of the fence
it is in our yards what happened in
maine is what keeps health officials up
at night
super spreader events that are hard to
track the epicenter of the main super
spread is millinocket
a tiny community untouched by covid19
someone brought the virus to the wedding
and within days it's spread to a jail
a nursing home and a church where the
wedding officiant is a pastor and noted
anti-massacre
who has now blocked his social media
seven people attached to that singular
event have died so far
yet none attended the wedding the virus
favors gatherings it does not
distinguish
between happy events like a wedding
celebration
or sad farewells like funerals
anywhere with a large number of people
in little space is considered high risk
in saskatoon health officials say a
party with 47 guests
turned into 21 coveted cases and the
london ontario health unit released this
contact tracing chart
which show how parties and meetups
between three houses of western
university students
led to 28 cases we know what we have to
do and i think it's
it's each of our roles to to not only be
responsible for our own behavior
but to be a positive influence on others
as well um there
there are some people who may think it's
not going to happen to me
um and uh and and that's the kind of
attitude that leads to these to these
events
super spread events are preventable and
when they do happen they are difficult
to contain
maine is seeing it firsthand once they
take root
it takes days if not weeks to contain
mike relay global news toronto
stamp of success up next yvc doctor is
being honored by canada post
few people can say they have changed the
world one of them is bc dr
julio montana during the aids epidemic
he revolutionized the way
hiv is treated globally now he's making
his mark
on a new canada post stamp linda
ailsworth explains
how many people can say they're on a
stamp dr julio montana can
when i first got the call from canada
post it was like
whoa ho what's going on here what's
going on
is that montanor one of the world's
leading hiv
aids researchers is being honored for a
career that began in vancouver in 1981
after he left his home in argentina for
a research fellowship at ubc
with the expectation that i was going to
go home and work with my dad in
pulmonary medicine
but he didn't go home lo and behold
i met my wife dorothea she was an x-ray
technician
at st paul's hospital where i still work
and the rest is history
at the time hiv had just started to rear
its ugly head
so montana hadn't given it much thought
but very quickly hiv became a concern at
st paul's hospital as you know
st paul's becoming the epicenter for hiv
aids in british columbia
soon montana found himself heading up a
very modest aids research program
it was myself and as i often say half a
secretary
i used to share a secretary and i had no
budget but by the following decade the
program
had grown as had treatment options the
biggest
breakthrough that we have come up with
in the last
six to 12 months relates to our ability
to suppress
the the viral replication the three drug
cocktail
triple therapy was the highlight of the
1996
international aids conference held in
vancouver
triple therapy turned what it was an
imminent death sentence into a
chronic manageable disease montana
continues to make new discoveries
as for the stamp the search for his
childhood collection has begun
i'm looking forward to resuscitate it
and just to include my own stamp
to the collection linda ailsworth global
news
well deserved that is global national
for this saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is meeting lake
regional park in saskatchewan
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com thank you for
watching and i hope to see you back here
tomorrow
have a great night